[music playing]
CROFTON DIACK: Cameras
aren't working,
and it's getting
super frustrating.
MAN: This is what it's
like on "Life Below Zero."
JOHN GRIBER: The camera's
already down, tough conditions
all around to film it.
CROFTON DIACK: No heat.
No power.
No anything.
Ugh.
It won't even turn on.
CROFTON DIACK: I've
fallen too many times.
We have bad winds.
This is a typical
day in the Arctic.
JOHN GRIBER: Making the
best with what we got.
[music playing]
CROFTON DIACK: It's super windy.
And our cameras aren't working.
And it's getting
super frustrating.
SUE: It is an impressive
storm, and I'm only supposed
to get a little bit of a lull.
So like it or hate it, even
though I've still got wind,
even though it's
still a blizzard,
I have to start moving the snow.
CROFTON DIACK: So it's
going get down to 20 below.
We have bad winds.
It's just blowing,
blowing, blowing.
And it's messing
with our cameras.
It's getting frustrating.
We have visibility
of 100 yards maybe.
It's just a typical
day in the Arctic.
They're filming at Kavik.
[bleep] winds.
[bleep]
JOHN GRIBER: What I'm doing is
setting up suit, clearing snow.
Ugh.
[bleep] you.
Conditions are a
little blustery.
[bleep] battery thing
keeps coming up.
And we're unable to do our job.
That's what I'm doing.
This sucks.
You can't really always rely
on gear operating properly.
Here's a top of a
building right here.
So we've gotten a lot of snow.
And a lot of wind has
moved a lot of snow.
So setting up these shots, I
really don't know if they're
going to work a lot of times.
But we want to maximize
our time out here.
So we've got GoPros
set up on Sue's bobcat.
You never know if those are
going to last very long,
or if those are going to fail.
And then we'll be
running two other cameras
watching her clear snow.
It's probably around 15
degrees ambient temperature.
But with the wind chill, it's
probably more like negative 15,
negative 20, I guess.
I don't know.
It's cold enough, you don't
want to touch anything
with bare fingers for very long.
Electronics don't seem to last
very long in the cold either.
CROFTON DIACK: This
is Sue right now,
trying to clear the path
so that our plane can land
at some point to pick is up.
But it's intense.
So to get this shot of her
doing it, we need two C300s up.
We need GoPros up.
And I need Sue to be
a bad ass and plow
a road through everything.
JOHN GRIBER: [bleep] Mark
II won't even turn on.
MAN: Seriously?
JOHN GRIBER: Yeah.
Making TV.
We'll see what happens.
The drone's a valuable tool.
I mean, GPS is just messed up.
And I don't know.
I'd hate to lose this drone.
SUE: Not a bad way
to spend a day,
digging a little snow cave.
I feel like it's important for
me to brush up on my skills.
And I'm not going
to wait until I have
to have one to
figure out, at 55,
do I still remember
how to make one?
JOHN GRIBER: It's
been kind of trying
with flying the drone lately.
Between super high winds,
incredibly cold temperatures,
I haven't really
been able to have
much success in keeping the
drone kind of where I want it.
I think we're so
far north that we
can't determine where the GPS
is, where the GPS signal is.
And so it honestly just leaves.
No matter which way I
push the controller--
left, right, up, down--
the thing, the drone
just takes off.
I mean, look at where we are.
There's a chance that I'd
probably find this thing.
Where it ends up,
I have no idea.
You never know what the
weather is going to do.
Zero wind, we've been
up here for two weeks,
and this is by far the
nicest day we've had.
See, right now, it
says my GPS is good.
Let's see what happens here.
Sue's walking out to the Argo.
And I'm really
hoping this works.
[drone whirs]
MAN: There it is.
JOHN GRIBER: I see it.
[music playing]
Just doing one more move,
and then we'll call it good.
That was a good flight.
That was the best one
of the whole trip.
for two weeks of flying.
This is what makes
me happy right
there-- the drone is down.
So that's great, and
we got a good shot.